Hello, friends.
Today, we'll learn about the Stone Age.
The Stone Age is a very ancient period of human history...
...when people used weapons and tools made of stone.
The Stone Age is a period of history in which humans used primitive stone tools.
Lasting about two and a half million years,...
...the Stone Age ended approximately 5,000 years ago...
...when humans in the Near East began working with metal.
This age is the first period of human history,...
...so people from the Stone Age were the first to create clothing.
People wore clothes made of animal skins during the winter months,...
...and clothes built from grass and bark of trees during the summers.